direction dijon maintenant on le
retrouve en direct dominique verdeilhan
alors dominique effectivement des ce dès
le premier jour tous les éléments du
procès dette en place oui tout à fait
avec logo soir de cette première journée
on peut déjà faire un constat on a plus
parlé de bernard laroche et de muriel
bolle que de jean marie villemin
c'est dire que le déjà le volet grégory
laroche a pris le pas sur le volet
villemain alors un glissement évidemment
qui a ravi la défense avec aujourd'hui
un personnage clé qui le personnage clé
de ce dossier de ce procès muriel bolle
l'épicentre d'un séisme familiale selon
l'expression de m chastan un glissement
qui en revanche est redouté par la
partie civile qui ne souhaite pas que ce
procès soit celui d'un mort bernard
laroche le planning des cinq semaines à
venir
et pourtant éloquent 16 journées
entières seront consacrés à l'assassinât
du petit grégory six journées seulement
à l'assassinât de bernard laroche
merci d'avidité que